[Music]
please don't get involved
let's get it baby baby it is monday
morning june 6 at 10 a.m on this lovely
calabash this morning what is happening
fam what's up thickies thick of tears
thick gums
three thicker musketeers
um that's all i got for you today what's
up guys how you guys doing oh yeah cool
oh your kid graduated kindergarten too
oh that's cool man yeah mine too yeah oh
they dressed up yep and then they didn't
give you really um the dress code so
your kid looked fly but wasn't in a
tuxedo or three-piece suit like the
other kids so you felt a certain way
about it you know so that's cool um yeah
he graduated kindergarten man big deal
for the kiddo big freaking deal
i don't when i was a kid i don't think
there was a celebration when he
graduated kindergarten i forget
case i don't think so
mark was there a celebration when you
graduated kindergarten did they do
anything oh there's no ceremony
our thing was just like last day see you
in three months
or however you know it's like now i mean
it was so
did i cry to graduation yeah i did dude
cause i wish i could freeze my kid he's
grown up too fast
we also had the annual when i say annual
it's the first one the debut uh thick
boy
basketball cookout
look andre petrovsky but at least that
hat is fire
throwing thick bricks
what i put i assembled the worst
basketball players in cal best for the
first annual think boy backyard
basketball tournament bbq speaking truth
yeah team now t hit
my son plays bad he's in a basketball
league he he's hit like 30 shots in the
road some [ __ ] and then he's like dad
filming this for mama i do brick yeah
would we play knockout yeah it's called
knockout yeah god that guy was intense i
wasn't ready to you know we the ufc
fight was going on so we were watching
that my and i think who's it kyle and
casey were up at the basketball court
playing with my kiddos
and cop kept texting me like yo man you
gotta get down here dude your kid keeps
asking okay i'm like just let me get
through this main event man and then
show enough
here's gin at least i made the
semifinals crazy game and i suck at
basketball in case we're the mvps though
you guys kept winning both of you i'll
tell you who's the real mvp uh i mean me
and casey obviously we have a weird uh
competition gene in us but um
i'm in vain and skinny jeans so i should
win just for that fact and i have the
biggest blister on my [ __ ] pinky
because those vans because i wear them
without socks
but then uh
mike big mike
freaking
dude big mike was like he's just
chilling watching we're like come on
mike please like i'll play one game big
mike's the sleeper dude i know super
sleeper no one great bambino
mike he won too he didn't miss a shot
either that big boy was not moving he
was hitting those free throws
knockout's fun man but dude i'm in
skinny jeans a pink hat and [ __ ] vans
with no shoes on what to even win a game
and i daddy was sweating i was so sweaty
i was so sweaty
ah that's right
i mean casey just kept wanting to play
more and more ooh that damn don't be mad
at the dance moves man
god dawg
get wider
that's a good time though threw the
barbecue for a big george really
through the barbecue for big george to
uh
my girl saw the thing with uh you know
us giving him a full-time job him crying
she was like i don't i've never met him
we should have him over and eat i'm like
we can't just have big george over it's
gonna be awkward
so you gotta have the whole squad over i
was like you don't even know them she
knows chan shows mark but she'll know
casey kyle big mike you know so we had
you guys over now here's the thing about
having people over
oh no here's the thing um now daddy had
to go to whole foods right daddy had to
go to whole foods spend some money
buying the meat and then great meat by
the way dude thank you you like those uh
uh whatever kind of rubbish they're all
they're
a little more flavorful because they're
marbled with fat yeah now daddy's grill
is a little older i've cleaned it many
times and because there's fat it catches
on fire so you're dealing with some
you know some optics there the the
flames are so high and when it's flames
you gotta constantly stay on it flip it
so daddy start cooking at around 11 30
before you guys came on round one
i was like a 50s housewife i was cooking
all day all day nobody said thanks i was
cooking all day so we did and then i i
know i was cooking all day you guys did
say thanks for
watching all day hours hours hours i had
a dude i had a charcuterie board i had a
[ __ ]
i did all my girls gone
and i had two kids bro my my interview
was i was going to come and you were
grilling when i can i did come a little
late but everything was laid out
perfectly daddy laid all that cut all
the meat for you guys
mark deep throated three hot links i
mean
throw zilla over there dude just
i was like hell yeah dude take that meat
mark take that take that take that
kids had so much fun with you guys
kyle you you have nephews
yeah you're too good with kids not to be
around kids because
when you don't have kids
they're a little like just i don't get
me wrong i don't let anybody take my
kids alone but then when you were
walking you know you have to go
through the backyard up the stairs the
basketball court
if you don't if you've never been around
smaller kids you don't even think that
oh he's two this is gonna be a beast for
him to walk up the stairs i'm gonna hold
his hand most people like see up there
dude and then run up there and then with
the basketballs like even big george
just grabbing the basketballs yeah
there's black widows in the [ __ ]
basketball where the basketballs are at
so you can't have a two-year-old jumping
in there again you know but you guys
were on it man
that made me happy
um let's get to fighting though [ __ ]
this barbecue it was fun though and
we'll do it again oh yeah you gotta do
more stuff like that because a tight
team is what makes the world go round
man
my girl knows you chin's been with me
forever forever but she didn't recognize
you because your new tattoo right she's
like who's who's the asian guy yeah is
he is he your new security i'm like oh
he's talking about chin's new tattoo
she's like that's generally yeah yeah
cause he used to be in a gang too nope
never been anywhere nope never been a
game let's not spread those rumors
uh there was some fights on uh
this past weekend you uh had a big
boxing match your boy haney uh flew all
the way to australia against camboso
and uh you know tough fight for our boy
george australia they say it was the
biggest fight in australian history
um yeah so it this this this this kid
haney man his fundamentals his jab
it's he's gonna be tough to freaking
beat he's gonna be really really tough
to beat now they have a automatic
rematch clause um and as haney said he
goes if i can beat him once being him
twice is even easier so he has the he
and he's only 23.
so i think he was a world champion by
the time he's 21 this dude got all the
belts going down to australia so he got
all the belts
um it was it was not a great fight there
wasn't like any moments where haney was
in trouble his fundamentals man
nutsos nattos you got a little
kind of like floyd mayweatherus to him
just again he's so [ __ ] good at
boxing and also his jab is so precise
and he'll just sit back on that jab and
pick you apart you know these guys kind
of they have to you know
jump in and make mistakes he just sticks
to the jab doesn't really get hit it's
very rare he gets hit kids can be a
problem man
kid's gonna be a big problem that was
fun i watched on espn that's like i
can't remember last time he's been had a
good fight on there for boxing that you
have to pay for that wasn't pay-per-view
um and then saturday at the annual thick
boy cookout
we had the uh ufc fight night on called
fight day though you know you had a
fight day on uh you know really take
away your your main event uh volkov and
rosenstroke listen everyone wants to
talk about this stoppage and [ __ ] like
that um i don't have a problem with it
cheering out a problem at first with it
but then when you watch the replay and
once we talked through it i think you
were more on board
i thought it was good stoppage because
rosenstroke right gets blasted with that
flush right hand he's on
sixth street
and then he's wobbled and then he lands
several other punches he can't defend
himself and then this is when i think
they should definitely stop the fight
and this is my case for it not being
early stoppage when you completely turn
your back
on another
savage who's ranked i don't know five in
the world six in the world when you turn
your back on this russian who's very
good at throwing kicks elbows and
everything the whole gamut when you turn
your back into defensive posture and
you're not answering back and you're
wobbled on sixth street
i mean what do you what do you want to
get a walk-off ko head kick you know
what i'm saying so
i didn't have an issue with the stoppage
just now if you would have sat there and
he covered up and you know you wobble
when he's covered up you can let it go
on a little bit if he's showing an
action to defend himself and he's aware
of what's going on
but when a fighter turns it's kind of
like uh remember when jds turned his
back you remember that and then was
upset about the stoppage like in what
world did you come up training where if
you turn your back and give up your back
on your feet to me that's that's all
turning your back
while you're in a stand-up brawl would
be the equivalent of tapping out during
submission to me that's the equiv
equivalent of tapping out in a stand-up
fight when you completely turn your back
and leave all
opportunity for that guy to fire off
whatever the [ __ ] your spine back your
head a kick whatever a takedown you're
kind of just going like oh my god i'm
out man you know it's different than
what aleister overian did if you
remember when aleister was doing that
weird run technique remember he'd get
his back installed and literally just
spread it out of the way which was very
strange but he wasn't wobbling and he
wasn't engaging in a fisticuff he was
literally they would they would he would
cross the black line as soon as his heel
touch it he would kind of turn
and then sprint back to the center
octagon it was a weird technique but
i mean the guy's doing the best to ever
do it so more power to him but with
rosenstroke is more of uh
you know to me turning your back when
you're engaged in your rock turning your
back is a tap out
on on the feet it's the queen of tapping
out during the submission that's a tap
out to me and the ref needs to jump in
there and stop it
you know because he didn't it was just
going to get worse for him you tell me
he's going to fire back no what are we
talking about so
i and i also said this as they're
walking out rosenstein will never be
champ
not having for him too small
uh not enough tools to compete in the
top five really unless it's a straight
up you know fisticuffs kind of caution
of the wind throwing from the hips then
yeah he has the technique and he's quick
enough where he can get it done but you
know you look at the top if you click on
his record chin you look at when he
fights those upper echelon guys he's not
he's not really winning those he's not
winning those so lost volkov lost the
kurdish blades those two top guys lost
cyril gone you know uh unanimous
decision okay
juno dos santos he beat older dos santos
and then uh he lost to francis yeah
remember he got mollywood by francis so
those top upper echelon guys he hasn't
beat any of them so let's out of the
guys that he's fought so arlovski not a
tip of the spare not a top five guy
you're gonna be wrong with the grace to
ever do it i beat him in vancouver
anyways um so he beat orlovsky he beat
over him oh older over him oh the ovary
one remember too i've never been sold on
rose and stroke if you if you go back
once in the show i've never been i've
never co-signed him not that i don't
like him i'm talking about as far as
being champ because if you look at his
record you know so
orlovsky to knock him out in 29 seconds
that's a big deal he's a vet but then he
fought aleister over him who's a real
vet and he can't just murk right away he
was losing that fight except for the
last
kind of 10 seconds then then he got over
there and then they give him francis and
francis absolutely bart simpson molly
wopped him literally france just ran at
him with his [ __ ]
helicopter arms knocked him out then his
dos santos again dos santos not a tip of
the spare guy you know he was also
orlovsky dos santos they were not
anymore so he's beating up these older
kind of legends
but when you beat that older legend then
you're getting to the creme de la creme
right you're getting the serogons he
lost zero gun really didn't have a
chance in that fight didn't land
anything got picked apart
and they go okay so and then so he'll
fight out bro schlong guy get either a
legend or a guy
not at the tip of the spare so
out beats alexa over him they go so he
beats orlovsky okay next step up here's
over him
he beats over him but let's be honest
he's getting absolutely annihilated in
that fight till the last 10 seconds then
they go all right you beat over him you
knocked him out that's cool man here's
francis
the champ
at that time was in chat but here's the
champ currently the champ he hit starch
in 20 seconds now i'm in the fight
all right you're not ready for that
here's juno dos santos older guy beats
him okay then then they tried again all
right man here we go here's cyril gone
top three guy
loses that not even a fight unanimous
decision
50 45
overall loses that they go
all right man here's uh
augusto saki he beats him
all right here here we go here's another
chance curtis blades top three
gets molly whopped gets what you know
decision not a great fight and cursed
blade's never really in danger molly
waps on the oh jesus christ dude all
right well we can't just keep giving you
these young lions or legends here's
volkov who's been a perennial contender
former world champion from bellator
here's this monster
and there's a fork in the road for both
of them and volklav absolutely dominated
and i i do think you know if you look at
cyril uh not sarigan if you look at
rosenstroke's body
there is potential and this is very
broken-ish of me there's potential for
him to cut down make 205. he's too smart
heavyweight to compete with the big boys
his fundamentals aren't there his
speed's not there his power's there but
outside that he's just gonna get
annihilated by those top guys so it
depends what he wants to do now he's in
a tough road you know he's lost three
out of his last four
three hours last four can't really
wrestle it's gonna be tough
it's gonna be tough him and curtis
played this fight a hundred times cursed
blade beats him a hundred times you know
then voc obviously is just too long too
rangy better fundamentals you know just
pick them apart dude so it's a tough
road for him it's a very tough road for
him
but again i'm not i'm not throwing any
shade on rosen stroke i think he's you
know he got what top five pretty fast
like he has skills he's power in his
background especially with his
background like the guy has some [ __ ]
talent man but i just think for the
weight class unless you have that steep
a or kane velazquez
type of body where you are smaller like
you're not the biggest guy but you're
smaller with a lot of power you got to
have some wrestling you got to have that
cardio you got to be able to mix it up
and he can't he's shortage his reach
isn't great and he's the bigger guys
like volkov
i listen ufc did him no favors zero
favors long rangey more fundamental more
experienced guy okay
you know main event five rounds cardio
ain't on your side homeboy you know so i
think they're if i'm his team i'd say
man how hard is it to get to 205 for you
now you go to 205 obviously you have a
the world uh title on the line this
saturday
on the pay-per-view you know
he's not he's not he's not that
yeah there you go yeah cannon there did
it now the discipline it's gonna take to
get the two now
i would uh let me let me see another
shot of his body here's one
so he definitely has more fat than me
these are facts but the thing is is when
i was thinking about cutting a 205 the
amount of discipline that it takes to do
that
it's not like you're just going to hire
nutritionists and then cut however what
do you weigh 250 260 he looks every bit
of 260. yeah what are you weighing at i
look at that you're talking about a
life-changing
decision this isn't something where oh
i'll just get into camp eight weeks out
cut down to 205 for him
so he weighed 260 pounds
259 to be exact
he cut 55 pounds
but he he could do it
he'd do it
or you can just stay at what you're
doing and you you know you might be a
top 10 guy but you're never cracking
that top five again probably especially
like the top five guys
but again you're talking about
the biggest decision you're talking
about a complete life overhaul where
your entire
life is surrounded by what you put into
your body working out so
you know how about how bad you want it
how bad you want it that's what i would
suggest for him again i'd i've been
around when i was eating i don't know
all that [ __ ] but you know yeah
um it's gonna be tough
very tough now him versus tai to avos is
a fun one
so there's certain fights you're like
you know there's certain ones
he's got he's a little bit like derek
lewis not as fun nowhere near as good as
on the mic not as entertaining probably
didn't have the same power you know
and derek lewis ground and pound is
filthy
but you know
a guy like tom aspinall i think beats
the [ __ ] out of rosenstroke
um
you know obviously tom b volkov
so it's just it's a tough gig for a man
it but again you look at he's ranked
eight now are these updated it's gonna
update tomorrow okay so he'll probably
drop down
uh philly's finest dukakis is gonna jump
up to eight i bet
be like at
you know nine through 15. he can hang
with those guys
but after eight up that means dicey do
so it just depends what he wants i don't
you know i don't know teach his own talk
about complete life overall though for
him cutting the 205. yeah he might hear
this and be like get the [ __ ] out of
here i mean a [ __ ] shred of lettuce
every three days dude
you know and it's not gonna be quick
either probably take you a year to to
really walk around about 225
you know and cut the last one he's six
that's he's six two now this is the
internet six two so he's really about
six one might be right over six foot i
bet 260.
yeah dude if you lose weight though
yeah you know chin how much weight have
you lost i don't know [ __ ] that's big
george out here yeah well if i got 250
pounds he lost just about how much he
weighs
so it's possible again you're talking
about complete life overhaul so that
that might be too much uh outside that
you know danny
uh danny iggy had a tough night in the
office
is dan again and uh
um whom i think
what right and rob are they not i know i
get it mixed up let's say it's a
spider-man meme you you you like are
they not the same guy oh it's so trippy
they look very similar
very similar
that mozart is a [ __ ] nightmare
i was thinking about this and then what
i think we have bryce uh mitchell coming
up about
four minutes i can't wait to talk to one
of my favorite people we're trying to
get him here for a food truck
but out if he's not fighting have to fly
for fighting he's fit he's killing fish
he's eating squirrels he's talking
politics gun control you know this dude
is he has red white and blue floating
through his freaking veins you know so
he's like man if i'm not doing promo for
the fight like if i'm not out there i'm
not you know i just don't i want to be
home like say last son i'm the exact
same man exact same
so i don't push anybody but we got him
on here on chop show he's one of my
faves
um
but uh uh mo mo far mo sar mozar mozar
evolve he's uh a bit of a beast didn't
he yeah he's give me a problem now
what's he wants uh his uh promo inside
the outgoing was terrible but um english
clear isn't his first language he's
russian i was thinking about this though
from the ufc
obviously russia is frowned upon right
now
with everything going on right
there's and now dagestan and all that
stuff over there they're not russian
right uh chechnya all that they're not i
don't know how it works we've been over
this nobody here is a geography expert
but what i do know is the ufc and it's
not i'm not saying it's a bad problem
but they do have an influx of russians
and dagestans coming in
so for the ufc it's as far as
the united states goes
is they're gonna have to figure out a
way
to
market these russians and dagestanians
better you know like not everybody's
gonna be a khabib not everybody's gonna
be a makachev and even mocktail if not
great on the mic it's just his fighting
speaks louder than words but the ufc is
headed towards a trend which i would
assume especially the hardcores that
watch this show like this where
winning
and
skills is what counts
not the entertainment value because the
ufc is losing their biggest entertainers
right the conor mcgregors the nate diaz
not these these guys can't fight i'm not
saying that i'm saying they're these
unicorns that had not only the skill set
to be some of the best fighters in the
world but they're also very entertaining
similar to wwe well they're getting
older
nate diaz has one fight left nick diaz
one fight max connor one to two
you you look at mazvidal
you know you look at it it's headed uh
you know that's kind of out to pasture
it's getting a little bit out there and
that's what they bank their notoriety on
so if i'm the ufc and they have their uh
i always reference their marketing
meetings i don't know when they do them
or if they do them at all i'm sure they
do but it's probably a group text or
email chain but if it's in person
i'm sure it's not like hey i'm just
curious are we set in america like is
that the plan like we don't think we can
get any bigger in america unless like
another connor or you know a colby comes
along like is that like what's the plan
in america because we have this influx
of dagestanians and russians who are
dominating
and you know it took khabib a while
before he got big you know it takes a
lot you they have to win how many fights
before we start paying attention and
their names are impossible to say and
also russia's killing innocent people in
ukraine so it's like
yeah yeah how do you how do we mark is
this man because if it's a global thing
you know i i don't know i don't know as
a business plan if you're dating a white
how you deal with that
you know because i know he said no
uh
flags flags right but i saw a flag i
thought on saturday night yeah i thought
i saw ukraine on a russian one
maybe it was just on the tv uh
maybe the audience or something like
that yeah you might be right i don't
know i thought i saw one but wouldn't
that dicey it's a bit of a dicey deal of
course it is you know what i'm saying
yeah
like if you're a russian stand-up comic
right now and you're sitting here in
portland this thursday friday saturday
it's like
you know
he's just i think it's to me it's
interesting they'll figure it out trust
me they have way smarter people than me
on the team so it's like they'll figure
it out i'm just wondering how
how do you go about that treading
lightly yeah do you stop signing so many
russian fighters
you know because these russians gonna
beat most your americans these dagger
standings are coming dude and their
names are impossible to pronounce how
are we going to mark this merch
do we just market today
but they don't identify as russian no
that's what i'm saying yeah no no yeah
don't get to us i'm not saying that
dagestan russia are the same i'm just
saying you have an influx of those guys
taking over the sport now
on the global scale but in america
you know
like even though
you know could be i mean now could be
if you look at his phone not that just
social media following is the indicator
and who's more famous or bigger but you
know you look at khabib's
instagram and because you know he's
dagger standing and also i'm sure a lot
of rush but he has so many [ __ ]
millions and millions of followers but
you know so you know i i wouldn't say
he's bigger than conor mcgregor even
though he beat him
he's there but i won't say bigger than
connor you know or in america if
khabib walks down the street to you know
pick up a diet pepsi or some thick boy
whiskey he doesn't drink but you get the
point it's a weird promo but anyway if
you want to go pick up some tiger thick
at specs in uh texas or somewhere or
online at thingboy.com but anyway if he
was gonna do that more people would
recognize say like a nate diaz than a
khabib in america like nate diaz or
colby covington will shut the store down
i don't think khabib would unless he
marketed it and his fans were like the
hardcores but i think in general the
general consumer would recognize uh
jorge mazar or nate diaz or nick diaz
more than it could be you know i'm
saying in america as far as marketing
what are they going to do
how do you market and when's this you
know when's this war stop
you know like you're banking on that
stopping and then yeah yeah it's crazy
let's take a little break and then we'll
get right back to the show man because
ufc 275 is here that's right it's this
freaking saturday man i can't wait we
got three big boy fights and lady fights
and my friends at draftking sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
the ufc has a heavyweight offer for this
weekend's fight with a special parlay
for all my listeners and viewers of the
shop show for the fighters this week my
picks are yeri shevchenko and waylay
alright listen
yuri we need to get it done the first
two rounds if you don't
our boy glover texera you get to my
breakdown at the end of this episode but
our boy glover is going to put a master
class
freaking veteran master class of
takedowns and beat his ass and probably
submit them in the fourth or fifth so if
you're betting on yuri we need it done
early with a flying knee spinning back
elbow something unconventional because
you ain't just gonna beat glover
you know how you can get it done but now
glover's head's always in the center so
it's gonna get dicey for him but has to
get done the first two rounds then have
chef chanko of course she's gonna try
and beat the most titled offenses ever
in women fighting history beating ronda
rousey which i don't want to bet against
but you could if you want to make some
money santos is a big underdog then you
got waylay against uh joanna which i do
think whaley gets it done and all you
gotta do is head to the app right now
under the ufc page to check out my picks
it's the shop picks all right bet on it
and ride along with your boy here i will
be watching from the green room in
portland oregon i'm at the helium this
thursday friday saturday but i will have
the fights on the green room so portland
come on support all right
right now all customers can place the
same game parlay for saturday's fight
and if it hits you'll double your
winnings download the draftking
sportsbook app now use promo code shop
show new customers can throw down five
dollars on
on ufc 275 that's ufc 275 pay-per-view
this saturday you get 150 dollars in
free bets instantly that's code shop
show this saturday at draftkings sports
book the official sports betting partner
of the ufc minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details
uh we ready for bryce mitchell
all right let me quit going on on this
maybe that's a question for bryce yeah
that's a good question for him let's
toss it to my boy thug nasty taking a
break from killing squirrels and fish
mr thug nasty bryce mitchell what's up
brother
oh just chilling like a villain man
thank you so much for having me today
yeah man i've i've wanted you on for a
hot second we've been communicating with
your team
and we wanted to get you on a food truck
and your manager's like dude he's like
you man if if
if he's not working he's at home he's on
the ranch or farm or whatever it's tough
to get this kid out of out of his house
so there's no complaints there brother
i'm the exact same but uh where are you
at right now man is that that's a legit
farm i'm looking at
yeah i'm in cersei right now this is at
my place and um you know i'm just
chilling today it was a rainy day i was
gonna bush hog but grass is wet and like
you said i really like to just stay home
and kind of work on stuff as much as i
can
and um
i'm kind of like a hermit you know but i
do travel i think it's good for you but
yeah but i really like being home i mean
i just love it i'm the same man there's
nothing like home you know there's
nothing like home and when you say work
on stuff yeah what are we talking about
work on stuff like on the farm are you
talking about like an mma like your
skill set or we're talking about you got
like hogs and chickens to take care of
what's what's happening here
yeah i got so i got chickens and cows
that i tend to every day in rabbits uh
for example let me just show you just
real quick and i'm going to come right
back because i like that
i want to show you okay for example
here's a rabbit right here he's a male
rabbit i don't know can you see him good
yeah i see him
so i keep him stacked up on bricks uh
you know that's just one of my animals i
got a turkey over there now my turkey he
got the isolation because
he's a convicted murderer uh he got he
got charged with murder he i put it i
put that baby turkey in the quail pen
and he killed a quail so now the
turkey's in isolation the rabbit he's a
nice rabbit but he he stays locked onto
those female rabbits and uh he pretty
much stresses him out because he's on
them all day you know what i mean yeah
you got a harvey weinstein rabbit's
there
that's right and what happens is if you
don't take that male rabbit out of that
cage and put him in his own little area
away from those females the females will
bite his dick off oh wow really oh dude
this is this is a learning experience
for me
i didn't know uh female rabbits bite
other rabbits dicks off and then i also
didn't know
turkey's murder other turkeys
well it's a quail it was a baby turkey
and the quail pen i thought since he's a
baby turkey he'll be okay with the quail
they're about the same size
but uh no he's he's a murderer so you
put that baby turkey in there with other
birds and they're like the alpha bird
they're gonna go in there and
uh and the turkeys they're the quail
even had a bodyguard they got a mama
goose in there and the mama goose didn't
do nothing damn dude you got the ted
bunnies of turkeys over there man now
are all turkeys like this or you just
got a bad you got an evil turkey a
sociopath turkey
well i think that if you raise them
as small little birds together there's a
chance you you could get turkeys and
chickens to get along
but
just in general if you take a turkey
who's a couple weeks old and put them in
a in a pen full of hens oh the hens will
pick them to death i mean they'll think
you're giving them a snack yeah
nature's a cool cold-hearted [ __ ] man
they and you know this better than
anybody nature is savage man yeah
absolutely so with the with this farm
are you is this like uh
are you making money off this like
what's the i guess you obviously love it
but is it are you being compensated for
it like what's the the point of all of
it brother besides loving it
well the only way i've been compensated
is the value of the land has gone up you
know since i've invested in the land
that's a given but um as far as like
monthly income no there's absolutely
none uh i do produce all my own eggs so
i don't buy eggs from store no more
um
here this this winter or next winter
probably this winter i won't be buying
beef no more either you know i've got
two steer out there out back that uh i'm
gonna butcher so you know i'm not really
looking forward to that because i like
them so much but yeah also i gotta eat
and that's the point of it and uh we
only eat the steers so all the mama cows
out there they'll live full healthy
normal lives but the steer yeah we
castrate them and eat them yep yep man
you're doing some some some man [ __ ] out
there on that farm dude now how
how far is the where you're at now to
your training do you have to relocate
somewhere else to get a full camp how
are you doing it
well let's see okay one
two
three
four
he froze on us he ran to his gym and it
froze
oh there he goes now he's back in the
spot there he is
did you get to see the gym
i didn't do the the the
i know the recording froze but it's
close so then you're flying in training
or you're having training partners come
to that gym
yeah a lot of my training partners have
been coming over now there's a gym
that's an hour away from me in little
rock
and uh uh you know i dropped that's hour
there now we're back and i go there a
couple times a week so it's it's worth
to drive though
yeah yeah driving
i used to do it here when i moved to l.a
you're talking about
hour and a half drive to orange county
to wrestle with mark munoz and
pat cummings and michael bisping you
know so hour and a half there sometimes
two hours there hour and a half back but
it's just what you got to do man but
that the sitting in the car after
training is what ate me up man it that
really tore up my body man
i like to listen to music and that's
kind of why i started rapping so much
because i'm always in the car so there's
nothing else to do but work on my rats
so
i use it as is time to invest into my
rapping which i actually liked it i'll
tell you what man is you know we uh we
did a thick boy album with this guy
named uh little brows and chin's on and
stuff like that and we played your
i think you were freestyling or
something but it was on your instagram
we played in here and chin knows you
know chin's backgrounds music and chin's
like dude
bryce is freaking good man and then
little brows who's a professional rapper
i mean makes a living doing rap he was
like dude this bryce mitchell kid has
some talent man i'm like and he's just
bullshitting around it's not like you're
you know like you've been working on it
this just kind of a undiscovered talent
i guess that you got
well i do it in the car like we were
talking about you know anytime i'm by
myself from the gym
uh
that's an hour there hour back i can't
do nothing you know i could do a phone
call or something but i don't even like
doing phone calls you know like work
stuff so i just like to get in the car
and do music and
that's one way i get to practice i wish
you would have got to see the gym but
the internet cut out but i've got a nice
little gym just right over there it's
just 10 i counted it took me eight
seconds to get to that door and that's i
mean in eight seconds i can be on mats i
mean so yeah that's amazing brother you
got a good setup man you're doing it
different than anybody i've ever i've
ever seen in the game as far as
just kind of being self-servant you
don't you know you don't need much man
you know you got that farm they got the
land there you're taking care of the
land they also got your gym there like a
legit gym you know you're you're a top
10 ranked featherweight in the freaking
world man what a story brother i think
for you
you know obviously your skills speak for
themselves you're undefeated you know i
think you can get a big opponent next
which we can get to
i think for you too it's like
you're one of the guys where
you know you're not doing it for fame
you're not doing any of this for
notoriety and kind of some of the
notoriety that came with you was when
you're so outspoken just about politics
which you know whenever you talk about
politics you know as a comedian
even as a as a fighter as politics we're
taught to hey man you can go that
direction
but if you go that direction a you're
going to get you know the lebron james
treatment shut up and dribble you know
shut up and fight then b you're going to
get
half the fan base who
and i'm not saying the ufc fan base i'm
just saying in general america you can
get half the fans divided right because
politics are so hot right now so when
you come out and speak however you feel
half the people are going to vibe with
it half the people aren't you know but
to me it's like you having the no matter
how people feel about it whether i agree
with you or not but i agree with most
your opinions i think a lot of it is
having the courage to realize you're
gonna get backlash if you talk about
certain subjects in today's climate you
know whether it's gun control uh the
pandemic lockdowns small businesses any
of this stuff you know the president all
that stuff you're gonna get backlash and
i think
for a guy like you to do that again
you're not doing it for notoriety you're
not doing it for that's a sweet cat dude
you're not doing for any of that stuff
but i think that kind of put you on the
map weirdly i think it made people more
aware of you and not to mention you're
undefeated you have all the skills
skills in the world you know is that
fair to say
you know and
and when i say something it's just
because i care
about about it you know and i feel that
whatever i was talking about before that
isn't as important as the issue that i'm
bringing up so if i'm talking politics i
just believe it's
it's something important that i need to
to say
and and i you know you're gonna get
backlash for it
but uh i just morally feel
that i should talk about stuff that i do
have some bit of understanding about
and uh
think about it like this you know our
careers as fighters it has a lot of
backlash we got the brain damage we got
the
every mistake we ever made people will
make fun of us
and
you know i mean the backlash for
fighting
is huge even if you go in there and even
if you go in there and have like a
khabib career he still has brain damage
and injuries and
and uh stuff like that so no everybody
pays a toll you get backlash for it
but
it's worth it if you can establish a
lifestyle that's worth living
and and hopefully help some other people
that you care about in the process all
that backlash all the negative stuff all
the hits and all the being made fun of
and all that crap it's worth it if you
live better and the people that you love
live a little bit better
and that's uh say same thing when i'm
talking i know this everybody's not
going to agree with it but if
if if what i've
what i'm talking about i believe needs
to be said i'll say it even if there's
gonna be some backlash yeah i think what
i love about you when you speak out on
this stuff and i don't think you should
stop i don't know if the ufc reached out
to you and said hey let's stay away from
this or stay away from that i don't or
your management i don't know but what
what the reason i like is the number one
reason why i'm a fan of you and and root
free and what you become champion is
because
whether anybody agrees with what you're
saying whether you agree with it or not
it's it's your truth it's natural to
bryce like you you didn't you know the
night before like oh this can be a hot
topic let me let me rip this promo to
get a top five fight no you let your
skills speak for themselves inside the
octagon and then as far as the other
stuff you're there's no game plan here
this is how you feel
you know what i'm saying that and that's
why
i wanted you on the show because i love
people who are authentic no matter what
it is dude i don't care what it is you
know and you and i talked before you
came on here you said you know i we
don't have to just talk about fighting i
tell the still fighters all the time
when they come on food truck they come
on this show but really food truck
you know for fighters i'm like hey man
if you want to come on i'm not a
journalist i don't break news i'm not
trying we'll talk about fighting but i'm
not a journalist
if you want to talk about fishing for an
hour bryce we can talk about fishing for
if you want to talk about this this ted
bundy turkey that you have let's talk
about this teddy turkey you know what
i'm saying so it's like
to me it's more of a connection it's
more of a feeling out and i'm a fan of
your work but i'm a fan because you're
authentic to yourself man that's what
i'm [ __ ] with well thank you my
brother and i've always liked yours as
well and speaking of that turkey you see
this storm shelter behind me i can't
tell if you can see it there's a big
concrete thing do you see it yeah i see
it
okay i don't know how good the view is
here because i can't hardly see my own
screen i got bad internet and stuff but
turkey was that like a bunker was that
like a bunker in case armageddon comes
for the turkeys it's for armageddon or
it's for twister
that's for a twister you put all the
animals in there every so i'm gonna put
a fence around that that storm shelter
and put that turkey in because he's
outgrowing this cage but i can't put
them in the quail pan and i can't put
them anywhere else so i'm building them
i'm gonna put a fence around that storm
shelter and let them in there the only
bad part about that is if there's a
storm which it's kind of storm season uh
if i have to go in there and close the
door it's going to smell like turkey
[ __ ] the whole time you know but yeah
yeah
what's the goal with this turkey is the
goal for this turkey around thanksgiving
we go ahead and end his evil life or
were we talking about here
i'm sorry you said you said am i going
to eat them for thanksgiving yeah well
i'm saying with this turkey who's
clearly has some mental issues with this
turkey are we going to is the goal for
thanksgiving to kind of put the end
of his life and eat them or what's the
goal here
okay so this is where it gets real crazy
my
my gym and little rock it went it
upgraded to a new facility and i'm not
the old facility was amazing i loved it
but for the average customer that's not
what you want there was no ac there's no
water fountain you know you drink out
the sink
you know there was a there was a osha
would have shut the whole damn thing
down if they would have seen the cage
for the fighters in the back the cage
had metal poles exposed right
and yes i've been concussed in that king
in that cage i'm sure yeah
and so the the cage was unsafe but when
they upgraded from the old gym to the
new gym which the new gym is pretty
extravagant i'm telling you like it's
very very nice
when they upgraded they sold that old
cage guess who bought it yeah you got it
daddy with the with that's right the
rusty
got a mma cage sitting right over there
it's i love it it's over there where i
parked the car in the truck and stuff
and it's all it's unassembled but all i
got to do is assemble it i'm going to
have an mma cage full of
be turkeys yes it's gonna be two stories
and i don't know if this turkey in in
isolation right now i don't know if uh
if he's gonna be
uh for a boy or a girl i don't know i
don't know which one he is yet i figure
here in about a couple months it'll be
pretty obvious
but uh for right now i just don't know
i'm gonna keep hopefully it's a boy and
then i'll just go get a bunch of girl
turkeys and then have them breed in the
mma cage and the mma cage is gonna be
two stories too because it's got a crawl
space about four foot off the ground so
i'm gonna jack that mma cage up on some
four foot posts and now you're talking
across space plus p piers that it's
sitting on and it's gonna be two stories
you're talking about two-story turkey
coop there with a
mma cage oh i dig that man now you're
using your brain doug
let's take another little break kids
with the shop show here leave the lights
on that's what pays the bill for the
staff the lights my shoes so here we are
man ufc 275 is here this saturday
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner the ufc has a
heavyweight offer this weekend fights
with a special parlay for all the
listeners viewers of the shop show this
is just for you guys my three fight
parlays yeri shevchenko and wayleigh if
they get it done you're making bank bro
they boost your odds just head the app
right now under the ufc page check out
my picks shop picks all right bet on it
and ride along with your boy i'm doing
it from the green room live all right
i'll be in portland oregon thursday
friday saturday but saturday the fights
i will have on all right you can bet
that right now all customers can place
the same game parlay for saturday's
fights if it hits you double your
winnings download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use promo code
shobshow that's sch aub show new
customers can throw down five dollars on
any ufc 275 fight and get 150 in free
bets instantly that's code shop show
this saturday at draftking sportsbook
the official sports wing partner the ufc
minimum age eligibility restriction
supply see show notes for details um
as far as the the current climate you
know not just talking about fighting and
obviously i'm sure you have some strong
opinions on this and so do i so we i'm
feel free to get into it or you can say
ah let's talk about fighting you know
with this gun control stuff going on
with these mass shootings
it's obviously a hot topic right now and
you know i'm sure you're pro second
amendment pro gun which i am too i'm a
gun owner you know probably six seven
guns
um
you know it's a it's a it's a dicey
subject man it's it's a little dicey and
i i always lean towards uh you know my
father-in-law was a cop for 30 years
i'll talk to him a lot about it um tim
kennedy is a good buddy so i'll talk to
tim kenney about it who's much more
educated on this stuff
where are you at on this
well you know i did a interview with um
ariel helwani
and i went on there and i said that
the the government is doing some school
shootings they're letting some of them
happen
and they're also like the las vegas
shooting i believe that that was a
government collusion the las vegas
shooting was too suspicious
too
too many things didn't line up and
anyway so i went on aerials and i said
that okay a couple months later you got
an ovate uh texas
uh
he gets an ar
is this kitten maybe not but a a guy
who's dressing up like a girl he was a
kid i guess he was 18 years old and he's
i don't know if he's here what he was
but he dressed up in skirts and stuff
and he goes in
with his ar-15
and starts killing people in the school
in texas okay fourth graders yeah the
police officer the police officer sit
outside
for about an hour
and they're they're saying oh well we
gotta we don't know if we want to enter
because of this we don't have enough
armor we don't have enough those kids
don't have any armor those kids are
unarmed and they're kids and it is those
officers when they when they swear in
the office those officers it's their
duty to go in there and die for those
kids on the spot that's their job it's
their job that day was to go in that
school and die or kill that guy that was
killing everybody and there should have
been zero hesitation zero and ex i'll
say the exact same thing that i got
censored for on ariel helwani's the
government is getting involved in some
of these shootings and in this one i
believe they were ordered to stand down
i believe they were ordered to stand
down sit outside that school while
innocents were shot so that they could
have a narrative to come and take ar-15
specifically and i'll say it again what
i said on ariel's i will die before i
hand over that gun i'll die in a
shootout before i get starved to death
because as soon as they take your guns
they're going to starve your ass to
death just like they did the jews back
in and ariel ariel was hating on me
ariel was saying that well he wasn't
exactly hating on me but he said i
spread misinformation well let me tell
you a fact
okay
government government took the guns from
those uh citizens in germany before the
nazis came a couple years later round
them up and starved them to death so i'm
just telling you what happens and i
maintain the same position and if i get
censored again i get censored again but
i believe that there was
something weird going on with that
school shooting i believe they're trying
to find any reason they can take our
guns and i believe i won't give it to
them i'd rather die we need to arm
school
teachers who can be trained and proven
that they're efficient with guns we need
to arm them we need to arm pilots if you
can fly if you can fly a plane
you can operate a 22
uh pistol caliber yeah our pilots all
have guns if you if i trust you with my
life to take off a plane and land it
that takes much more skill than point
blank shooting somebody with the 22
pistol so all the pilots should have
guns some of the teachers should have
guns
some of our tax dollars instead of being
sent to the ukraine should be spent more
on our veterans
and our kids schools
no that's just a fact
yeah no i i agree with you on that bryce
i think as far as the misinformation
goes
you know
there's
i don't know if we get all the facts
right so i think with that with that
shooting just from
what i've heard and having some people
in the situation it's like
they definitely i think it's you know a
small town in texas they definitely
didn't act accordingly they made some
huge mistakes
and then from what i hear from from cops
is because that's what i i was like you
know i i have a kid who's in first grade
now and i have another kid who's in
preschool so
you know when they told me that they
wouldn't let the parents into the school
you know i i said i said it on the show
i said there's not a a police uh
force in this world that could keep me
out from entering that freaking school
man they would have to shoot me in the
back because i'm going to that school
with my guns there's if people are
waiting outside i ain't waiting bubba
you know what i'm saying so
but but when i uh expressed this to a
cop
he said
he goes i don't have all the facts but
what i do know is that turn from an
active shooter to a hostage situation
which is why they waited outside
you know so that so they told me that's
why it took so long that like what
that's why they didn't act you know
which is
you know it's dicey man
that's the best defense that they're
gonna have that's the best defenses that
there was hostage and guess what's wrong
with that that the whole hour gunshots
were ringing out so i'm sitting there as
a cop and i'm here boom that's one less
sausage boom that's two boats yeah at
least four
there was at least 14 booms
you got to know you got to know this
ain't no hostage situation you hear 14
booms sitting out probably more
and i'm just telling you i personally
would have [ __ ] run in i would have
died before i would have sat there and
listened to 14 booms go off
they agree believe that
the chief is ultimately responsible and
he should be charged criminally in my
opinion the chief should be held
personally responsible and should be
charged criminally yeah there should be
some accountability yeah there should be
some accountability if you're not going
in there you're talking about fourth
graders and i think as far you know
again
with the misinformation nobody's gonna
send you here you do your thing man
speak your truth whether you believe in
you know that's your truth so as far as
you know the the transgender i think
what happened then i i fell into the
same thing is
as soon as it happened
i people are sending notifications of
old post from the shooter that uh he was
transgender apparently that's the wrong
person it wasn't transgender really yeah
that was someone who looks just like him
and that person came out was like whoa
i'm not the shooter this is me i'm
transgender but i have nothing to do
with the shooting that's what i that
that was information i got back to me
but again i'm with you i was like oh
transgender shooter because that was the
narrative off the bat but again in
today's media we don't know what's real
what what new what you know who's
leaking what so it's tough to filter
through all this gossip and get down to
the nitty-gritty and at the end of the
day there's fourth graders who lost lost
their lives and this can't keep going on
now when you said school you know the
teachers should have guns
it's not a terrible idea i just you're
asking a lot from the teachers i have to
deal with teachers all the time with
parent teacher conference me and stuff
like that
my
my idea would be is to have armed
security guards who are trained whether
they're former special forces or former
cops whatever someone who's familiar
with
you know um guns to arm the school
because you know in california alone
which you know california is a [ __ ] show
but you know during the pandemic they
raised a billion dollars for school
funding
how how you know when ted cruz goes well
let's make the doors safer so they can
lock them so you know these active
shooters can't come in or
a billion dollars you can't hire two
armed guards to monitor these schools so
a not only is he gonna
have the active shooter or someone who's
thinking about shooting up a school to
think twice if they see two armed guards
with experience with ar-15 sent out
front and you know salary wise how much
are we talking about here to to arm
these gentlemen at every school man
yeah i believe that's very reasonable
putting some armed guards to schools and
the best solution i can think of is
is uh just homeschooling your kids i
mean it's sad to say that because i like
the social interaction that that the
public schools bring or even private
school what any type of social
interaction i think is good for a kid
but if i had kids right now i what i
would not let happen is i would not let
some teacher with the mask cover in
their face
talk to my kids like this all day and
teach them that this is healthy with
this mask over their face if my teachers
were wearing masks i'd pull the kids out
of school luckily i don't have kids but
i wouldn't would never make my kid wear
a mask ever and then um and then say
that the mask issue goes away and the
vaccination issues go away
then i put my kid into school now i'm
worried about some school shooter going
out there and the police not doing
nothing and it's just it's scary bubba
it's very scary as the father is scared
to be 100 honest with you brother if i
had kids it would not be an option they
would be being homeschooled right now
and guess what the teacher would know a
lot more [ __ ] than they're being taught
because i think the school system just
makes these kids stupid and let me tell
you why because you're you're not
encouraged to think outside the box
you're taught to do stupid [ __ ] and most
of it's not even gonna matter like your
trigonometry your calculus all that
you know they don't want to teach kids
about the nature of the federal reserve
about the nature of the economic history
of this country how there was a
mandatory gold buyback i believe in the
30s you know they're not going to teach
our kids that they're going to they're
going to teach a narrative and make them
stupid
the more you dig around the more you
figure out that the government um
you know pretty much has an agenda with
our kids education i don't like with
what's going on and here's what the
educational system is is
is for
it's a it's a parents use it as
babysitting mechanism you drop your kids
off and let the government employees
teach them whatever all day what it's
basically babysitting okay
uh but
but here's
the thing is like
they're not they're not learning real
valuable stuff okay they're learning to
do work that they don't want to do
because that's going to translate in
later in life to condition them to do a
shitty job and pay their taxes
you know they're going to train your kid
to be slave labor as their life goes on
work at some shitty job that they don't
want to work but ask no questions and
just shut up and pay your taxes
the school system is about conditioning
you to not think outside the box to be
stupid enough to uh to never try to do
something for yourself
uh to just be a s to just be a stupid
worker and pay your taxes and hate your
job and um you know that's what we're
doing
monday through friday yep and to be
happy with happy hour
yes and i think the private schools are
homeschooling will fix that educational
problem because our government
government-run education system are
piss-poor they're unsafe and they're
just they're breaking our kids down
mentally we thought then you get them
eight hours a day eight hours a day and
you want to send them home with homework
[ __ ] off agree [ __ ] off i agree
there's some schools changing that
though yeah like my son's school they
they make sure they don't have too much
homework where they do most of work
while they're at school it's a private
school to be fair but they're making
sure that they learn between the hours
and then when they're outside that
they're being kids which is really
important to me
i think that being kids is so much very
important brother and you know teaching
them to clean a fish teaching them to
to shoot a deer and clean it and things
like that should be taught and how to
how to grow vegetables and
just the basics of life you know how to
provide your own food that's the last
thing that the government wants though
is everybody to provide their own
healthy food and way of life because
then they won't have their slave workers
that they can tax to yeah yeah that's
where you come in papa when you do you
have a girlfriend right now
i i sure don't brother
oh wow i'm surprised you don't man i
mean top ten in the world you got the
land you're freaking smart kid you know
you got your [ __ ] together handsome dude
look at you these glasses you got the
button up so
you know if you had a kid i think
you know the as far as the fishing and
the hunting stuff like that that falls
on the dad you know i'm saying a lot of
it falls on the dad because
that teacher unless your teachers you
know your fifth grade history teacher is
cam haines nobody's gonna teach that kid
to be a better fisher hunter than bryce
mitchell that's where your son's gonna
grow up having this knowledge of and
what you're doing now you know you got
your masters in in life as far as
hunting and fishing and being
self-independent so it comes down to the
dad there man so i think you'd be a
great dad brother if you ever think
about it we gotta work on getting your
lady first but
yeah that's right yeah that that comes
first because
you don't want to do it the other way
around you know have a kid and then see
if it's the right lady
yeah that's a nightmare that's about
like buying a car before you test drive
it um
let's get into fighting man because i i
definitely want to talk to you about
some of that stuff you know because you
know i think it's you know your opinions
match your truth so i think it's
important
and now when you look at the landscape
as far as the featherweight division you
know you're top ten in the world
um you know you have big fights coming
up
you you did ask for a top five fight you
know and before you came out i looked
through the the rankings
you know the top five guys are pretty
tied up right i i'd love to get your
opinion as far as what would be next for
you i mean you know a guy not in the top
five but i think would make a lot of
sense but depending when he's going to
be healthy who's a big name and the
legend of the sport would be korean
zombie even though he's coming off a
loss i think that's easy work for you
it's a big name it keeps you you know
keeps the winning streak rolling but if
you want a top five guy i think you're
waiting a while man where are you at on
this
yeah you know my manager made that tweet
he's trying to get me the highest ranked
guy can but
um that's what he's supposed to do so
but for for me personally
they pretty much know whoever they tell
me to fight i'm gonna fight so i didn't
make that top five tweet or i don't care
who
i fight that's their job is to get me
the best fight but i will have to just
sit here and agree with you the koreans
on me is the highest ranked guy that i
could possibly fight and the reason that
i believe it he is is because he's a
two-time
title contender you know he went and
fought for the belt two times correct
and so there's other there's other guys
that are up there that are uh really
high ortega's booked uh holloway's book
you know they're booked uh but there's
other guys that might be up there but
they didn't fight for the belt twice so
if you go in there and then you beat
zombie better than both champs aldo and
bolt beat them
i think it took both maybe two rounds so
i'll go in there and beat korean zombie
in first round okay girl that gives me
grounds to fight both immediately i'll
say i just thought dude he fought and
did a little bit better you know and
that would be the best fight but um
if they don't give me that fight i
pretty much just say yes to whoever they
give me
and
um
you know my management does a really
good job
with getting me the best fight that they
can but at the end of the day i have no
say so but i completely agree with you i
want to fight the zombie because he's
the best guy available
yeah i think with zombie it's just a
matter you know he said he wants one
more fight so
it's when is he gonna be ready to go
you know you don't want to wait you know
too long so it's like is korean zombie
ready to go he says he wants one more
fight you'd be a great you know test for
him i do think you beat him in the first
round that's no shade on zombie my
producer loves green zombie he's also
korean but um so
you know if you don't get korean zombie
again those top you know you got calvin
kadar you got emmett fighting you got um
uh ortega yaya rodriguez they have
voglanovsky max holloway so it's like
those top top guys are all busy so it's
to me just depending on when korean
zombies healthy and ready to take a
fight to me that makes all the sense in
the world
yeah there's i have no control over that
but hopefully he's ready to go
um you know in a couple more months and
i also think it's twist reverse twister
so one of us twisters each other that
settles it right there who's got the
better twister that's what i said
brother it's twister on twister crime as
i was talking to the team earlier to him
i love korean zombie for him a little
twist around twister crime man i think
you pull it off um
how do you think you match up with those
top five guys when you look at them like
an ortega who's a jiu jitsu specialist
obviously you've been doing a lot more
striking lately but yeah ortega
yay rodriguez you got calvin keator you
got alexander volkanovski who's
obviously the champ who recently had on
food truck you got uh you know max
holloway
how is there guys you see that you you
can really kind of expose and take
advantage of or i know it's a tough test
but with your skill set obviously
grappling your thing wrestling's your
thing is there certain match-ups that
you prefer over the others
i want to fight for the belt and i think
i'd win all of them
i think whoever they put me in there
with i'm winning
i mean you have to think like that right
brother so i think for you it's like
you know your management's obviously
done a good job with you and it's just
you know styles make fights so it just
depends you know i'd say you're
you know if you get korean zombie you
mop him the first round that you know
there's debate you know if you could
fight for the title i i think the
argument would be volkanovsky took on
short notice you know you outclassed
them beat them up
um so you probably you're probably two
away from a title shot you know if you
go screen zombie then maybe fight the
winner of cater emmett or something like
that or the winner of ortega rodriguez
and that's title shot my man and then
that belt's coming home to the farm you
wrap it around the [ __ ] turkey you
know what i'm saying
i put it in the gym in little rock
oh yeah
yeah
because the people in that gym were the
people in that gym were a part of that
so that's where that belt's going to go
it's going to go on the wall or up at
the front desk in a case
that makes sense
yeah i mean you have all the you know
i'm always room for you brother you have
all the the skill in the world and
you're doing it at the beat of your own
drum man i'm a fan because you're an
original there's not a lot of guys like
you out there
um
you know we're rooting for you here
brother and i i think that sky's the
limit for you and um
you know i think it'd be really special
for you to bring home that belt back
there and the way you're doing it you
know doing it on your terms stuff like
that
does your management has does the ufc
ask you to kind of pull back the reins
and not maybe talk about certain stuff
have you been told like hey man let's
back off because
obviously you you were all over fox news
you're you know you're getting this
major kind of you know marketing now you
know being kind of this outspoken
political voice
um
does anybody tell you to pull back or
you just kind of you don't listen to it
you do your own thing where you at on
that
not a bit brother i've not heard
anything negative from dana
and uh that's
in my opinion that's the best thing
about dana white
is that
that is the best thing he lets those
fighters say what they want and truly be
be free with their first amendment you
know
and uh
i'm very fortunate and i think that
that's what i think i'm saying a lot of
normal stuff but
that a lot of people think but about the
vaccines and the corona and the
political corruption and all that crap
but they will literally get fired from
their job you know
and um
so it's really nice that dana just lets
me say stuff and
um
you know and if anything i actually got
more interviews before that barbosa
fight than i did before the fight before
uh so if anything they were maybe egging
me on because they were get i had like
three interviews today that i showed up
for the fight week you know so
if if they didn't want me saying stuff
they wouldn't give me none of those
little pre-fight interviews
i agree i also think you know it's kind
of the elephant in the room as far as
the ufc goes but i think dana agrees
with you on most this stuff you know
dan's obviously a super pro trump guy
super anti-lockdown guy he carried
through through the pandemic
you know so
he was the number one
uh leader of like big companies in the
pandemic because like they tried to shut
down all the big companies like all of
them correct and he really he brother if
it was anybody else i don't know they
might have got pushed around you know
what i mean they might oh you're not
going to open your show and blah blah
blah he said [ __ ] y'all we'll we'll do
anything we got to we'll go to abu dhabi
you know yeah good abu dhabi do it in
our you know in in our freaking office
at the you know the ufc uh institute
there so i think there's no i think
other businesses take notes like what
dana did pulling it off trying to lock
down and you know being self-sufficient
and still putting on shows during the
lockdowns and
you know
dan and i have had our issues but i've
never been a bigger fan for him figuring
this out and then not only do you figure
it out but it's clearly a smart business
move because last year that they had
their biggest year ever and also now
it's like
running the fights out of that uh
ufc was it the ap some institute running
uh fights yeah the pi my bad you know
the pi
but him running fights out of there he
realized oh i can just do fights out of
here you know it's like i don't we don't
have
yeah the apex center like we don't have
to be a traveling circus like i can run
out of here numbers are still good the
fighters like it it's not in front of
whatever 40 000 people but
we can still do that stuff but now we
can cut costs save money the fighters
get fights the fighters get paid you
know so he had that they also had uh you
know dubai so it's like man for a guy to
figure that out on the go
running a billion four billion dollar
company hats off to a man i get nothing
respect them
yep man i kind of like the apex too with
the no crowd a lot of people don't like
it they like the crowd i like the
silence but
i mean i also i also like a crowd when
they're cheering for me you know they're
cheering me on the crowd
but i don't have anything bad against
the crowd i just really like the silence
now
certain fighters need the crowd yeah
certain fighters need the crowd like you
know i think with conor mcgregor justin
gates there's certain guys that really
thrive off the the crowd whether they're
booing or cheering they they need that
energy
but yeah for you it makes all the sense
of the world i mean if there's no cro
you're an introvert so for you it's like
you're recluse you want to do your thing
do your job get back to the [ __ ] farm
and take care of this ted bundy turkey
man so yeah it makes sense you don't
like the crowd
right right it's to each his own you
know
yeah but um man i appreciate the time
brother i know you're swamped dude
taking care of all these animals and
getting training in figuring it out i
think you're gonna get a huge fight next
and you know we're we're rooting for you
here man and keep being you brother no
matter no matter what people say no
matter you know what what comes from the
interviews you do you just keep being
your authentic self and could never go
wrong man and you know people love you
brother never get twisted social media
is the loudest but that ain't the
majority people love you man
oh thank you so much brother and i
really appreciate you having me on and
you just haul her anytime and
you got my number now so uh i'll be i'll
be watching your shows too so man i
really appreciate you brother and take
care man you hauler anytime oh there you
have it oh yeah so there's a signal
issue at the very end but he said come
to the farm or whatever anytime right
yeah cause i told him maybe next time we
could go out there a little
shop show
in the wild yeah go to bryce mitchell's
hometown go on the farm
he said he's he bought an octagon which
is going to uh convert to a turkey cage
so the top will be turkey's the bottom i
don't know that's dope yeah that'd be
fun though
interesting dude man you know whether
you agree with you know some stuff you
know with the you know the government be
involved in the shooting stuff like that
you know i don't really
vibe with when you talk about you know
fourth grade and stuff like that but
obviously some that those that shooting
stuff's alarming but um
it's my thing with him whether i agree
or not he's speaking his truth which a
lot of fighters and you know people in
sports are scared to talk about because
they're worried about the backlash and
bryce mitchell is not i don't think he's
too worried about social media and stuff
like that so
you know i definitely vibe with him on
that stuff man as far as him speaking
his truth whether i agree with all of it
and it's a little somewhere a little
conspiracy maybe you know to teach their
own
uh what do you got jim but i love bryce
metro man i think he is gonna get a big
fight i feel like uh
the idea of him fighting korean zombie
makes a lot of sense he said he says his
fight he wants yeah that's a fight it's
just
predicated on if korean's i'll be gonna
be ready to go yeah
in korea that'd be dope and that's what
he goes uh honestly though if it ain't
queens i mean i don't care whoever they
call me with a fight whether it's top
five or not he goes
i didn't ask for top five my management
did he say but i'm down fight whoever
yeah that's bryce mitchell
great kid man
very respectful to her like the way he
just said you know super nice things the
entire time though nice man really nice
kid yeah okay so this is um anthony
smith once again
and uh michael bisbee on their podcast
they have a new podcast together right
well it's it's bizman's old podcast but
smith is a new co-host oh nice yeah i
love anthony smith yeah he's great bison
is great too yeah that's a brilliant
pairing yeah so before remember they
talked about the whole dan bilzerian
stuff okay and we don't know what's
exactly yeah you know where the truth is
there but so here's trending again yeah
because they're thinking out loud
basically because they're saying like
these boys trying to make news they're
trying to get the subs up possibly but
okay so you know so they're talking
about usada
and then conor mcgregor
he these i think anthony smith was kind
of wondering like so how how does usada
actually test them if he's on boats
going around the world and just like
they'll get you
trust me the usada will get you so uh
this is anthony smith on uh the believe
you me podcast bisping and anthony smith
this is anthony smith he says i do
wonder though i'm gonna get
[ __ ] [ __ ] for this how do they test
conor mcgregor floating on a boat around
the world all the time i've wondered
that when i see him on his boat all the
time granted he's probably not posting a
real-time exec where he's at all the
time seemingly though he's on a boat
most time is usada sending people in a
[ __ ] helicopter drop on connor's boat
no
yeah i you know i a i don't think we
know conor's schedule right i think his
management and his wife knows his
schedule
but then also b
the way you sought it works and say you
know they do show up unexpectingly i
think if he's on a boat it makes it a
little more challenging so
here's a point there where if he is you
know and you have to let him know about
your whereabouts so he has to be like
hey i'm going from
bali to wherever i'm going from
you know
where the hell you know
england to freaking new york wherever
wherever wherever the hell he's taking
this boat i don't know where the hell
he's jumping island island or country to
country he has to notify you sada so
usada might say
cool when you land in new york
you know
that as soon as he lands they're doing
something so if it's this weird
conspiracy theory that he's doing
perform performing enhancing drugs while
he's on the boat and the way he lands
he's clear i guess
you know but they'll catch him
eventually if that's what he's doing i
don't think he is yeah you know i really
don't
uh and it's very simple they don't i
think you started testing him listen i'm
not going to sit here and say he's doing
steroids maybe he's taking something to
help the bones and and the rod the ted
the titanium shin bone to help it heal
and fuse together that was bisping well
that'd be like hgh or something like
that i mean but it's not necessarily
he's saying is he's not sure if it's
necessarily a steroid but something
maybe something like very advanced that
helps him do it
who knows
and also i don't see his social media is
he just posting on yachts on the ocean
all the time
always just him and his family on a
yacht that's kind of dull quite a bit
yeah yeah all right well yeah maybe
there's something there i don't know
i don't know i don't know if anybody
knows yeah but i mean if you would like
to really think about it you could go
five days on a boat with enough food and
everything and just
do what you got to do no don't get
twisted he's not on like some little
dungy boat like rowing he's on a yacht
with chefs yeah who knows what else you
know food like ditch that there's a
whole staff yeah interesting topic
though yeah that's fun yeah okay so i
think big john mccarthy was getting some
sort of crap about this but he was
saying that
if nick diaz actually fought kamal
oozman kamar uzman would get lit up and
want to go to the wrestling
big john
yeah these boys doing this for the
headlines i don't know but that's like
i said there's one thing you know about
nick he's gonna come and give everything
that he's got uh would i mind seeing him
against camaro no i wouldn't other than
this kamar would stand with him until he
started getting lit up god i don't think
tomorrow's gonna get lit up on the feet
man john have you seen uh camaro who's
been fight lately and nick lately yeah
have you seen the two
uh this isn't nick in you know 10 years
ago this isn't strikeforce nick now
granted nick is nick a better
overall boxer than camaro yeah maybe but
as far as
in today's world come on oozeman's the
better striker as far as power you know
look what he did the knocking against
mazda which nate couldn't do you know
what i'm saying look what jorge did to
nate his brother who
i think we can all agree is probably
more dangerous currently where he's at
in his career you know so
it's a weird thing so kamar would stand
with him until he started getting lit up
and he's going to go and use his
wrestling which he should i'm not saying
he shouldn't but what does nick always
complain about people wrestling and then
it's on the ground it's going to end up
being yeah he can try and use his
submission game and stuff but i don't
think camaro would end up standing up
with nick that long
that much out of the first round things
would start to become difficult i
disagree
i think komar
probably finish it yeah yeah
on the feet
i i think everywhere yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah one
pound for pound best fighter in the
world the other guy has fought once and
how many seven years it's been a long
time don't get me wrong for taking that
much time off look good but not
world title good
no you know john's also an old old head
so he's thinking of nick diaz you know
prime striker i'm dsp
not a great fight for come on prime diaz
but apples to oranges here we're talking
about right now son that fight ain't
happening either way so it's almost
worthless talking about
all right so a quick one regarding the
last fight that just happened this
weekend so felice herrick she fought
carolina kovakovic and carolina was on a
five-fight losing streak and finally
submitted um felice so felice decided
she said if the universe says that you
know that i lose this fight that means
it's there's something else from me so
she's retiring and moving all of her
attention to only fans oh good for her
yeah hopefully she'll make some money
i'm pretty sure she'll make go subscribe
to felice herring's only fans right now
i would she's a dime piece but also she
also saw a quote by her saying like if i
can't be champ i can't compete with the
best i need to get out that's the right
mindset yeah you don't want to stick
around too long before you're you know
drooling and damaged yeah
um so this is enemy junkie they uh
referenced the shop show mm-hmm the
whole patty pimblet tj dillashaw thing
that's going on right now
so is it it's based off of uh
the interview you had with tj what are
you saying like the diabetes like patty
pin was gonna get diabetes he's gonna
last 11 years in this you know in this
sport
if he's eaten this way so patty saw that
yes he said he went so here is uh and
there you are right there okay
um so this is uh
so patty went let me see patty's go up
top so let me see patty's original
response
where was that
right there yeah
so patty said patty the baddie at the
ufc batty put not as sensitive as your
body to that epo when you cheated emoji
cheating little juice head would never
have won the belt without them steroids
you [ __ ] mushroom mushroom okay
sense of subject
and then
uh
wait
so is this is this another one here yeah
okay let's go from here then i think
okay so he says this fella messin tj
duschal used to sell t-shirts with his
fat face on it saying fat tyler and when
he came out of camp don't forget your
own pass you sausage cheating little jew
said would never have won the belt
without them steroids you [ __ ]
mushroom right so that's the full
tweet
and then there's a tj said wasn't even
trying to be mean
uh at ufc batty getting all sensitive
must be a tasty subject drop the donuts
and take the advice the only difference
of fat tyler is that was a joke lol
what's not a joke is you getting
diabetes let's see how you look after 11
years in the ufc good luck lasting that
long
all right
fair response
fair response i think and again tj said
it on the show with tj
he was just saying
as a professional you know former world
champion he's fighting for a title like
when tj talks you might want to listen
especially a younger fighter so tj's
been like
as an overall
you know game plan it's probably not
smart to get that big and cut back down
like it's kind of not very professional
that's all you're saying i don't and i
told him i said yeah liz with patty's
young he's doing his thing he's such a
good kid he goes yeah i like them but
you know obviously the mma media runs
with these narratives and then patty's
obviously has no filter and fires back
but yeah i think overall that's why tj
is like dude i wasn't even trying to be
mean i'm just saying as a professional
it's not the way to get the best like
down the road to me dicey yeah but then
tj no matter what he says to any fighter
any fan it's always going to be oh you
jew said oh you p d head like he'll
he'll never outrun that as much as it
sucks it's like it's you know it's it's
what happened though yeah yeah it's a
shame
definitely i love both of them
for sure um so you guys know about the
surgery oh i woke up to this yeah the
boy cheeto food truck dropped last week
event seen on thick boy one of my
favorite people in the world cheeto
was asking for a big fight he wanted uh
peter yawn that didn't happen so now
him and dom have a history they've been
you know looking for each other on
future i think he said he wasn't really
into it he's like i've moved past them
beyond that but now
main event
cheeto vera dominic cruz agreed august
13th main event five rounds
it's just a right step for our boy
for our boy cheeto yeah it's a great
fight for him
love that fight yeah huge name uh real
quick one from one championship dj
demetrius johnson he's gonna rematch
adriano i forgot his last name audrano
who beat him yeah he beat him yeah he's
with ko by like a knee yeah it's bad
um maurice maris
yeah so he's gonna rematch him what's
the rematch
it is
friday august 26th august 26th all right
u.s prime time friday august 26th i know
one championship it made some big
announcement that they're coming to
america like they're doing a lot of
fight more fights in america cool good i
don't know if they announce where yet
but yeah it's supposed to be some big
announcement
um and also a quick one i think sage
northcutt and
shinjayoki should be fighting in one too
yeah that's the thing that's good
oh it's
uh sage versus
yeah that makes sense which is good
because sage just got freaking destroyed
let's face it
all those broken bones though good for
him for sure
uh brother this was kind of shocking
john dodson have you you know john
thotson right from him yeah we came up
together yeah so he signed a multi-fight
deal with pkfc interesting
because you know he's not known for his
boxing you know what i'm saying yeah
but yeah bkfc must be paying because
these boys are signing left and right
over there these former ufc guys are
coming over there so they must must be a
tasty paycheck for them to sign up for
bare knuckle fighting yeah yeah
big signing by bare knuckle man you know
yep
yeah hopefully they're making money
all righty uh greg hardy also he's gonna
have his first
i think is his first professional debut
in boxing
um
yeah
so his thing since he's left the ufc
he's gonna go do uh box professional
boxing yeah makes sense
and that's for black sheep boxing
october
boxing yeah
and no opponent as of right now
i mean you know you're gonna make a
fraction of the money in boxing it takes
a while and boxing get up unless you
have a massive mess of fallen like the
paul brothers it's that's a dicey road
yeah you know
and those guys have been boxing it
depending who he's fighting they've been
boxing since they were kids it's not mma
man we can start late and kind of get
you know into the rankings and fight
veterans boxing's a different animal the
sweet science you know to
dicey yeah career choice so it so like
if you're going to mma especially you
said heavyweights
i guess it's somewhat easier to easier
to like get to the top because it has
been around that long you can specialize
in one thing boxing you know this is one
thing one thing man if you're fighting
guys you've been doing forever you know
unless you're fighting other guys at
your level but then they're not names
it's kind of a waste of time then
they're what they're banking on greg
hardy to sell what tickets
you know it's a tough gig
um so i didn't know about this guy but
bone nickel is like a very good nickels
son yeah the producer of this show you
know bo nichols very well decorated
wrestler oh my god savage
born in rifle colorado that's right chin
colorado dude
but uh his debut in mma
i'll just show you right you guys are
expecting heavy wrestling but he knocked
this boy silly and the wrestler looking
like a striker here early he's got clean
strikes for for being such a dominant
wrestler and you can see the image
oh
that combo is filthy
that's an awesome date before him uh
bonika i would bet bow nickel in the
next year signs with the ufc
savage
wrestling wise complete [ __ ] savage
all right um let's do two quick ones
here so kayla harrison we've been
talking about her on firing the kid as
well toughest matchup exactly so julia
bud who's legit super legit yeah so
that's july uh july first pft definitely
uh yeah for sure phil harrison's career
by far julia bud's no punk
that's good that's a good one um beck
rawlings is back as well the dime piece
she's fighting britain heart who's uh
that guy jos joey
the guy that could just take hits like
crazy
oh um
the next thing yeah just training with
him anyways but she's now like either
fiance to him or married or something
but yeah so that's all right yeah that's
burton hart she's facing back rawlings
nice always a backgrounds fan over here
uh-huh
is that it brother um let's do one more
okay this is gonna get going everyone do
it this is a freaking really scary one
okay
i'll just play the video for you and you
can see what happens here and this is in
south africa
[Music]
so he didn't get knocked out of the
ropes he falls through
[Applause]
[Music]
watch this and then he looks like he
carries him like he wants to fight and
he doesn't know
throwing punches he doesn't know where
he is
[Applause]
no
this happened
so that is so scary so he's the one that
actually knocked the other dude into the
ropes and then he was so messed up yeah
maybe he's fighting a ghost
i don't know maybe he saw a spirit in
the corner it looks like it yeah body on
him it looks like but that's for some
bear got some chin
uh that's free wow that was
not good
yeah boxing's a hell of a drug that dude
was straight up fighting a spirit in the
corner yeah that was freaky uh you have
a i think a tasty pay-per-view three of
them are really tasty the rest card you
know tough but
uh the top three are fantastic you got
zhang weilei joanna young check
chevchenko and santos and then the main
event is for the light heavyweight title
glovertex era vs yuri
these three fights i freaking love i
think you could have even done as the
main event uh waylai and uh yuana
because you know talking about one of
the greatest fights ever
i would say to go on a limb i think
greatest female fight ever and then top
five men or female fight ever in the
women's star weight division it's always
tough to live up to rematches but
stylistically these two do it man i just
now is it going to be as good as the
first one probably not that would be
insane it's gonna be [ __ ] good though
so if that first one was a 10 this would
probably be a nine it's just their
styles it's a great freaking fight also
before when rose who's beat both of them
right twice for rose
if she was champ this is like all right
he's gonna fight rose and lose a third
time but now it's like
you know you have uh uh carlos spars is
the champ so whoever wins this
gets a shot back at again the title and
then rose is gonna win one and then you
get that rematches way more
you know story there i dig it uh then
with ah listen with uh shevchenko and
santos
shefchenko is not young now if she wins
this fight it'd be the most titled
defenses in women's
uh fighting history should break ronda
rousey's record
now there's part of me that goes all
right chefchenko who's just gonna get
lit up right because she's the most
dominant female fighter on the planet
so it's like all right is this santos
who's undefeated i think that she's one
fight away from beyond feed i think she
lost her first ufc fight right
yeah she lost a split decision so if
that split decision which split could
have went either way you know the
judging we
know how i feel about judging so
off of shitty judging where she lost
splits in this girl's basically 20-0
against chef chanko
you know a part of me wants to put money
on santos a slight pardon me once but
even though chef drank is so goddamn
dominant part of me thinks santos can do
it it's not a walk in the park for a
chef tranco it's just not
she's so talented i'd love to see her go
up a weight class especially she's beat
julia pena before she can go up to
weight class fight for be champ champ if
pena gets past amanda nunes what else
are you gonna do with pena chefchenko
pena makes a lot of sense especially if
chefchenko starches santos i don't think
she is but she is if she does that's
that narrative there and the main event
with glove tech sarah
yuri's one of my favorite fighters to
watch he's
so unorthodox he's a savage right
um
so part of me wants new blooded there i
think it'd be great for the ufc that if
yuri is champ he's so fun entertaining
his style is entertaining
but then
and i've met yuri but i've trained with
glover i know glover glover's
one of the top five nicest people
definitely the nicest champion you ever
meet he's such a good person he's the
oldest champion to ever do it his story
is history it's damn near impossible for
me to root against clover you you just
i love that he's champ now i love what
he represents i remember when he came to
ufc i think he was on a 20 fight win
streak he came over late because the
visa issues by the time he came you know
people thought he was past his prime he
loses jon jones gets absolutely
annihilated by jon jones remember john
blows his [ __ ] shoulder out or
whatever
you know so it's just such a great story
man so it's tough to root against the
guy
i just i think new blood would be good
for the ufc but
it's damn near impossible to vote and go
against global texture it's just
impossible tough fight for him he's an
underdog
it's gonna be a matter of glover who's
meat and potatoes getting the job done
against a very
tough
fighter and yeri who's so unorthodox you
can't bring in a guy to mimic his style
so if yuri doesn't get it done i'd say
in the first two rounds with a flying
knee or something wild you're gonna see
a master class from a world-class
veteran taking them down beating them up
eventually submitting yuri that's what i
think
so those first two rounds you're so
dangerous he's so explosive you soar on
unorthodox if you can't get it done
those two rounds
again you're gonna see a master class
from a veteran who trained with
chuck liddell in his prime
and freaking went toe-to-toe with him
and we've heard all these legendary
stories about him at the pit and all
this [ __ ] and finally he's here so
giri he has to get done those first two
rounds with his unorthodox style with an
explosive knee or you spinning elbow
some wild [ __ ] because you ain't just
gonna
outclass glove attacks here it's gonna
take something very special to get it
done so um
you know it's tough to bet against
glover it'd be good for the division but
i i i'm not willing to
go against glover even though he's a dog
here it's just such a a
happy story inspirational story but
those first two rounds will get dicey
for glover and if you can't pull it off
you can get it's gonna get
sad for him because he'll get taken down
glover's
grappling and jiu jitsu is very
underrated even though it's world class
his grappling so good you know but his
boxing style he's set up to eat some
shots he walks forward he doesn't really
choose his angles his head movement's
not great with a guy against yuri it's
[ __ ] trouble man there's a reason why
years -195 you know
so
top three fights are fantastic
i'll be watching from portland i'm in
portland this thursday friday saturday
portland oregon i'm at the helium it's
an all new hour the trash panda tour is
this thursday friday saturday in
portland oregon helium come get some
with the thick boy squad uh wednesday
one show one night only shauban friends
it's june 8th at 8pm at the hollywood
improv i have my boys all the way from
new york the boys from are you garbage
are doing the show you got crystalia you
got frickin uh jeff dye britney schmidt
we have the killers man one show only
and we have special guests come get some
hollywood that's uh this wednesday 8 pm
one show only that [ __ ] will sell out
let's go portland oregon's this weekend
thursday friday saturday in portland
then san francisco is the following
friday saturday i'm at the cobbs
uh
comedy club in san francisco california
june 17th june 18th two shows friday two
shows saturday that's it let's go kids
let's go get tickets fort wayne indiana
just went on sale july 14th through the
16th san diego california's july 21st
through the 23rd get your tickets at
thickboy.com or
fatkz.com that's it kids hopefully you
enjoyed my boy bryce mitchell just one
of the
most original authentic dudes on the
planet love that guy and that's it enjoy
the fights this weekend uh yeah glover
yiri shevchenko you got uh wayleigh and
you got freaking uh joanna it's a great
card so
be safe out there man be nice to each
other thanks for liking subscribing
watching listening whatever you do man
stay thick love you guys i'm out
you